to say the number of people who've been
no platformed or sacked or something
isn't the whole issue at all no you know
the issue is the culture
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
lecturer and writer dr jim butcher
welcome to trigonometry thanks folks
thank you very much it's great to have
you on the show thanks for coming on uh
you are a part of the don't divide us
campaign which we'll get into in a
second and we really wanted to talk to
you about uh the race equality charter
in british universities before we do
that tell everybody a little bit a
little bit about who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us well that's a
great question i'll keep it brief um
well i'm from derby in the east midlands
originally
i worked in further education for around
10 years in the west midlands in
birmingham and i've been down at
cansbury at canterbury christchurch
university for the last 20 years
over most of that time i've been
involved in the ucu trade union as a rep
i'm a big football fan
i'll mention the team so i really can
have a good laugh derby county
and uh
i also volunteer with um
an asylum charity and sort of mentor uh
a young man who's come over here
uh and uh i mentioned the race equality
charter which we'll get into in a second
but you've you've been in further
education that sounds like most of your
adult life would that be broadly yeah
further education for 10 years higher
education university sector for about
20. yeah i am that old yeah and i don't
like you your age aside what i'm really
trying to get into is you've been in
that part of our society yes for a long
time what have you
observed in your time in in in that
field what have you noticed what have
been some of the big trends that you've
noticed over the last 20 30 years well
some incredible trends really i mean i
mean one that i'll skirt over because
it's not perhaps so central to what
we're talking about here is the growth
of the use of the internet when i
started out we still had paper memos
three a week that you look at and put in
the bin uh ten years later it's 30
emails a day that you must answer
because people know if you've not not
read them and things like that but i
think the most significant change
has been how um education has become
very instrumental in relation to all
sorts of other things you know it's
never about the knowledge now and the
skills and the thing that you love and
that the students want to learn about uh
you're always answerable to some metric
some graph or something like that
i think for a lot of the time
in fv that became a kind of bureaucratic
burden but i think the thing that's
really taken off in the last 15 years
perhaps
is the growth of exactly the same thing
a kind of managerialism a tick box
mentality a whole load of bureaucracy
and a whole lot of kind of instrumental
goals that we have to meet related to
so-called social justice
and the one of course we're talking
about today is race but other things as
well
and so they started to come in 2005. was
it a particular event that kind of
precipitated this or was it an organic
thing no i'm not saying it came in 2005
i think broadly i've just noticed that
the growth of these things and it's
actually more recent than that i think
that it's become a really really big
issue with things like the race equality
uh charter tell everybody about that
what is that okay well the race equality
charter is like a kite mark or a
certificate uh that university is trying
to get
to show their commitment to fighting
racism they get this certificate from an
organization called advance he
they're funded by government and
universities
and they deal with training and teacher
training and things like that
if you look at the politics of advanced
he though you can see that this
race equality charter actually uh is all
about well
critical race theory decolonization
white privilege uh microaggressions
these are all there on the advanced he
website in the training materials and
that kind of thing this is happening in
universities anyway but the race
equality charter provides a kind of
impetus for ratcheting that up um and
encouraging universities to go further
and i think they're a real real threat
to free speech free expression
i think it's very patronizing and i also
think ultimately it's self-defeating
it's incredibly divisive
and when was the race and quality
charter implemented
well um it's been around for a few years
but i would say that um
this is a kind of big year for it it
seems to be right now that um in the
aftermath of black lives matter and now
we're kind of all back after the
pandemic as well
it seems to me that universities are
going very strongly for the race
equality
charter but it's not all about the race
equality charge i mean universities are
doing this anyway
a body called universities uk uk which
is the body of university leaders they
were already in documents around
race
talking up and affirming critical race
theory very openly that's a big thing
when you think about it
the leaders of the university sector
body that represents them saying this is
the theory that explains and the one you
should think about to help you explain
the issue of race you know universities
should remain neutral in that respect
precisely so people within them the
students and the staff
can have that freedom and feel free to
question to put forward other theories
but they're affirming these theories it
makes life more difficult for naysayers
heretics and very reasonable people who
just want to know both sides frankly
yeah well jim if i'm a normal person uh
not i don't know what that means exactly
you're not making i'm not
that's what that's what i'm trying to
acknowledge here i'm definitely not a
normal person because i kind of have a
sense of what you're talking about and
some of the problems that stem from that
but if i am someone who is uninitiated
in this discourse as as the people now
say
what's wrong with what's wrong with the
universities trying to not be racist
what's wrong with the charter that says
we need to eliminate because you know
some people are still racist in society
absolutely around surely it's a great
thing for our places of of learning to
be working to eradicate all of that
people might say yeah no i'm i'm all for
getting rid of
racism although i don't think university
campuses are as they're sometimes
portrayed of hotbeds of racial
discrimination but of course there are
racist incidents of course that happens
and that needs to be dealt with i think
it has been in the past i think one of
the great things about universities as
well is that all of those people coming
together from different backgrounds
there's a kind of lived anti-racism you
know young people meet other young
people from other backgrounds they make
friends they break down barriers that's
been happening for decades and that's
that kind of conviviality has been
really really positive
kind of thing so yeah that's really
really positive but what's actually
happening with the race equality charter
is a set of ideas that encourages people
from the day they step into the
university very often in their induction
as we found out you know at st andrews
and kent this week we might talk about
encourages them to view themselves as
white privileged i mean you might be
you might be from a working-class family
and struggled on your way up but you
walk in that door you'll be told you're
white privileged by somebody who's doing
rather better than you and perhaps your
family were doing as well which might
not be so easy for some people to take
it's divisive it encourages people to
focus on
uh differences to treat people as
members of groups rather than than
individuals who might you know
contradict your expectations about that
group
um so i feel it kind of
a lot of it's very well meaning but i
feel that very often it kind of revives
uh sort of re-racializes the university
in in a certain way and makes it more
difficult for people in their daily
lives
and daily struggles to break down those
barriers for themselves
why is it that critical race theory
it's a theory why is it suddenly been
taken to be fact that's what i don't get
it's all very well to have a theory
all theories should be taught absolutely
absolutely and i've very vocally spoken
out against
very occasionally in america you get
people saying ban critical race the
arena university is very very very very
rare
absolutely i'm saying that's nonsense
you can't ban critical race theory if
you disagree with it you want it out
there part of the discussion but part of
a discussion not validated by your
employer you know how many students are
going to if they feel like it they might
not they might agree with it but how
many students if they feel like it are
going to write an essay critical
critical race theory when the department
says
we are the decolonized department we are
the critical race theory university and
that happens
how many members of staff are going to
speak up about the divisive consequences
well people are
but it's difficult when your employer is
training the students you teach training
not discussing telling them how to
decolonize how to
uh sort of enact critical race theory
you know it makes life more difficult
the theory no problem you know it was an
old theory from from sort of critical
legal studies interesting theory
uh you know you go forwards um
what is it about 40 years 30 years
whatever and i think as in that book
cynical theories helen pluck rose and
james lindsey you know they described
how some of these theories
have become kind of
policies at the level of everyday life
um
and that is what we what we're dealing
with a very kind of intensive
kind of ideological uh pressure to
conform and think in a certain way
not to discuss the theories
but to enact the theories
and one of the other things you brought
up there is the idea of decolonization
and i find that very interesting because
every job i've ever had whether it's
this whether it's comedy whether it's
when i was a translator has always
involved looking at words and
understanding their precise meaning and
using them correctly yeah i don't
understand how you can decolonize a
university to colonize something means
to invade a foreign country and take it
over and use appropriate its resources
how do you decolonize a curriculum or
university well it's a very flexible
term i guess
and it is taken to mean different things
um
you know many many different things and
uh you know so for example to review
reading lists so that there are more uh
writers of color on the reading list
because those writers of color will be
more
representative or will sort of chime
better if you like with uh students of
color who come into the university
um so revising reading that kind of
thing there's a big philosophy behind it
and the philosophy behind it generally
is the idea of
de-coloniality
or de-colonialism and that holds
to put it simply
that
when we go to university there are
different
systems of knowledge different types of
knowledge that historically have come
from different places and the knowledge
we use
the western knowledge has crowded out
historically those other types of
knowledge
and therefore we need to bring those
those things back in
but
it's the theory it's an idea to be
discussed not to be imposed that's the
first thing
um but humanists and many many people
who fought colonialism and anti-racism
past beliefs something very different
which is that knowledge is human
universal yes there's all sorts of
different things going on but we're part
of a
sort of global
discussion across cultures across time
across place
and we ought to try and work out not
you know let's include people because
they're from this tradition or this
color let's try and work out what's best
for humanity for all of us
and that might mean
it might well mean as people like ken
and malik and others have argued it
might well mean including
uh black philosophers that have been
neglected absolutely it might well mean
it what might well mean including
working class geographers who've been
neglected however we need to have a
basis to judge what is the canon you
know what is what we teach and that
basis has to be a universal
one i think you know where we have some
criteria and some sense of what is the
best knowledge irrespective of where it
came from
that's a problem isn't it because with
this entire theory is that you're not
judging ideas anymore you're judging
where the ideas came from and who the
ideas were
were you know supported by or said
it just seems that we're just
delving further into the
how can i put this into into the the
black hole that is identity where it's
not about ideas it's
race gender sexuality etc etc
absolutely i think i think that's
exactly right i mean
in effect what it ends up doing
i think is putting people in boxes if
you're a student of color
we're going to have these but we're
going to look at getting these new
writers on the curriculum for you
now you you may not
you know really really really it's it's
got to be about the ideas and we
shouldn't make any assumptions that
somebody from this background this
battery on this color this guy i mean
the whole point of going to university
at the end of the day the exciting thing
intellectually about it is you get to
experiment and you get to try and
you know you've got your lived
experience you've got your own culture
that's very important for you and very
important i would never decry that
but when you go to university you want
to try and look around you know and
maybe in a way transcend that
not forget where you came from
but look around and think about ideas
that maybe have a
veracity and applicability way beyond
anything you'd ever lived you know
that's exciting
and a lot of young black white every
scholar you know good students that's i
think what they do
you know they're fascinated by the
subject by the history by the science
whatever it is
they're not thinking about the identity
or the colour of the person who came up
with the idea but they are now
they may be they may be and i suppose um
it is a problem because of course
you know you look at many of the um
great ideas if you look at darwin's
origin of the species i mean
darwin's boat and his
uh his journey was financed and sort of
bound up with you know victorian
imperial
uh britain at that time
but does that decry from the origin of
the species
you know yes i don't think well
well i'm saying hashtag i'm saying it
i'm saying it doesn't
and i'm saying that that knowledge today
is available and should be made more
available more available to people in
this country and other countries who
don't have access to it and the same the
latest science i don't really care
if you know where it came from um it
should be made about available to
scholars in well-funded universities
in poorer countries we should be looking
to do things like that and help and and
and sort of
share the best that is thought and known
that good old classical liberal idea is
one that i hold to
it's difficult but i still hold to it
well you say it's difficult this was the
question that i was really going to ask
you
do you think those of us
who
reject the idea that life should be
viewed primarily through the prism of
your identity
that we've lost
we've lost
at the education level we've lost in
policing we've lost in media we've lost
in even in sport god
i don't know how that happened but still
in every area you look at it is now
absolutely normal
to view
representation of different people as
the number one priority it's more
important that a media organization has
the right number of people of the right
demographic characteristics then that
organization produces good reporting
it's more important that the intake of a
university is ethnically mixed than that
it is fair and based on the merit of
those individuals in every i would argue
in every area of our society now we're
at a point i feel that
we're not even having that discussion
anymore because it is now accepted that
that is how it must be done
do you not do you not see that
i see i see the point but i don't agree
with it and i mean you could say i'm
obliged to disagree with it because i'm
i'm sort of
not representing but i'm a member of ddu
and we're trying to push don't divide us
don't divide us yeah have a look it up
uh but this is what i'm putting together
i want you to challenge me on this yeah
we're already divided i would say you
your your incantation is don't divide us
but you're speaking to a society that's
already divided as well i i don't think
we are i i think that
um you know you look at social trends um
i mean i just off the top of my head i
read the other day that you know
increasing number of black and white
people are getting married in america
you know america where this race war is
supposed to be going on on the street
young black men and white women
and vice versa are getting together
and and getting married so the people's
lived reality contradicts uh some of
this stuff if you look at opinion polls
as well for example including in the
universities it's it's not the case that
decolonization is something people come
and say yeah we've got to support this
it's not the case that people come in
committed to that a small a relatively
small number do the problem is when they
come in they're made to feel that this
is
the norm this is like the wallpaper you
know it's there this is what anti-racism
means if you're a good guy this is what
you do
so what it really takes therefore is for
people and it is it can be difficult in
some respects
people to
provide an alternative to that
and i think that's what we're trying to
do at ddu because we're not only
criticizing um
things like the notion of white
privilege as a principal in universities
and all that kind of thing but we've
also started and it's in our response to
the race equality charter propose some
slightly more
positive things i mean very balanced
well a very very simple one virtually
every university if you look on its
website um especially around this time
when it's black history month
uh coming up i think
that they put out what they call kind of
anti-racist
reading lists so students are told you
know racism is really important and i
agree it is of course
and here's what you read to understand
it and and to inform your actions
now you look down these these
anti-racist reading lists that
universities put out they have the same
names on them
ibrahim kendi
um renato lodge
uh critical race theorists derek bell
all of these kind of things one side of
the argument okay so one of the things
that we're saying is
yeah racism is really really important
issue we should be looking at it we
should be debating it why don't we put
out reading lists that say well
yeah let's look at what
somebody's saying on this side of the
argument
but why not read john mc water or
somebody else from the states who's
arguing
something rather different
read both
and we can discuss
isn't that a better thing to do at
university than to provide a wholly
one-sided
reading list that completely neglects
reams of scholarship reams of history i
might add because a lot of very famous
writers think as an anti-racist from the
past did not buy
the politics behind decolonized i mean
famous people of the left
anti-colonialists like clr james their
politics was not that of today's
sort of decolonizers and so on
i'm really interested i'm not a
historian but i'm really interested in
engaging with these history debates
precisely for that reason i'd really
love and one thing we really want to do
is engage with critical race theorists
people who disagree with us
but that's not always forthcoming you
know when you look for those discussions
and debates why is that
well you'd have to ask the people
concerned but if you're
don't divide us i know that they sent
out some invites uh to advance he the
critical race charter people and various
people associated with that saying look
in good faith let's have a discussion
about this
the response we received to a number of
emails from advanced he was nothing
nothing not a word
now we have over 100 academics well over
supporting us
our academics are told at university we
have to answer emails within two days
yet this professional body
gains not even to respond to requests to
debate and i actually think that's quite
outrageous but indicative of a sense
that this is the view
well this is you don't you don't debate
this view it's not obvious
this is exactly my point which is why i
say
why i'm questioning i'm desperate for
you to prove me wrong but i'm feeling
myself becoming more cynical by the day
because
you are i would argue naively sending
out these invitations to people whose
entire world view is based on the idea
that they have the truth and you are an
evil racist bigger
and they don't want to debate the two
different sides they don't want thomas
sol or john mcquarter or glenn lowry or
whoever else to be represented in that
conversation because they're not
interested in conversation they're
interested in taking over the
institutions which i put to you they've
already done
it's a good point i mean i i think that
as an organization trying to
um put a point of view we have to assume
in the first instance good faith
although maybe that's getting stretched
a little bit now but as i said before um
many people engage in this
entirely in good faith on the other side
um you know and i find this you know and
sometimes
it can become a bit of a self-fulfilling
prophecy to assume you know the other
person doesn't want to
discuss this i mean that you're right
at the level of so-called you know you
sort of professional anti-racists and
race trainers and people like that i
mean they have a material interest in
in that and they generally won't engage
but there are a few people you know
there are in any given university
hundreds of lecturers
people like you and i they're interested
in ideas they're open to discussing them
so that's where we've got to look and
maybe it does mean uh developing new
forums and different ways of doing that
i mean things like your show
um all sorts of things like that
um so i i'm
i'm not
overly optimistic but i'm an optimist by
nature and we're going out there to put
our point of view
i find it resonates with students i talk
to i find it resonates with lots of sort
if you like neutral people ask most
people isn't it at the end of the day
they want to get on with the job and
meet people and find out about stuff and
all the rest of it
so
that makes me optimistic um
and i think the more you go out and put
the ideas to regular people
the more optimistic you get because i
think our ideas are convincing i think
they do chime with people's lived
experience you know people come to
university they don't want to be
thinking
has he raised his eyebrow at me that
could be a microaggression right there
you know people want to be open to say
what they think
you know to say to somebody who's being
aggressive you're being aggressive and
not to think could that be a
microaggression
i mean the classic one on the subject of
microaggressions uh where i always break
the rule is asking people where they're
from apparently you're not supposed to
really do that
most of my classes are very very diverse
we get lots of young black kids well i
say kids adults young adults from london
and people from kent and people from
around the world
um very often the majority of the people
in my class happen to be black neither
here nor there to me i'll say where you
from
and they can interpret how they like
i have to say in 20 years never had a
problem with it made a lot of friends
through it found out a lot about people
through it that enables me to
maybe bring to bear examples in my
teaching you know that they can relate
to maybe where they're from is a place
i've studied um so it's a great thing to
do to ask people where they're from yeah
it's a great thing nobody should be
feeling
should i say should i say shouldn't i
say this and it's a real shame i think
that um the advent of this new sort of
critical race politics
it actually makes people check
themselves and not be spontaneous
and when you go to university you want
to be spontaneous you want to have fun
you want to meet people
you don't want to be able to you want to
make a few mistakes even there's nothing
wrong with that that's a you know we're
going to learn that way
um a culture of sort of standoffishness
if you like
doesn't benefit young black people young
white people or anybody else so that's
what we're going to call the episode jim
butcher why i agree with
microaggressions
[Laughter]
but yeah well to me jim
there's two questions that i want to ask
you number one what's it like being an
academic under this in this particular
kind of atmosphere
and number two isn't the rubber going to
hit the road when someone gets fired
because of this that's the moment we're
really going to hit the mainstream with
it
okay
well
and that should answer your first
question i love it i really really love
it in fact when i went in my class after
covid you know i hadn't talked for a
long time i nearly burst into tears it
was so wonderful to be stood in front of
a class of people
nobody wearing masks
me not wearing a visor which last time
i'd been in a class i was wearing it was
utterly utterly wonderful and i got a
bit carried away with it
but well
so it's great and i work
in a business school at canterbury
christ church
and i work with terrific colleagues you
know we we negotiate all this stuff and
and we get along we've got along for a
long time utterly terrific and that's
what a lot of it's like
you know
that's that's what a lot of it's like
i'd be lying if i said there weren't
tensions you know opinions that i've
told you earlier before we went on air
opinions that i have uh sort of gender
critical views that are regarded as an
athlete by people on my own union
committee i'm a member of the union
committee committee
but we you know we try and negotiate
those things and and do the stay in the
room with people you disagree with you
know sort of that that kind of
kind of idea so it's really really uh
good in in that respect
um i wish in general that education
focused on knowledge and education
but as any academic will wins you about
and it's true there's so much that's
instrumental you fill in a form to say
you've done this you prove you've done
this
you do you and then of course you do
your decolonized training and all of
these other things which i loathe and
when i raise
my point of view in it maybe i'm told
jim we don't make the rules you know
so it's that kind of attitude you do
those sorts of things
but um yeah i i really enjoy it and i
wouldn't try and talk anybody out of it
but i think if you've got
if you like
views critical of
you know the the sort of critical social
justice
i think you've got to
um
what's your back is is is the wrong word
but i think you've got your friend
well
i think you've got to be cunning i think
you've got i've got to be just aware of
the political issues and
and the way they play
uh and the possibilities
for you to be in trouble over
very inoffensive things that happens i
mean you've read about it i've read
about it that's happening to people
but you've got to front that up you
can't you can't what's the point of
carrying away you know
what's the what would be the point of
giving up a job lecturing talking to
young people
educating them it's a great job
all the problems
tell it like it is
put it out there i'm trying to do that
today um say what you think other people
can disagree with that more people who
do that the more open it becomes the
more hopefully we can get back to well i
say back to the never was a golden age
we can get back to knowledge
ideas facts skills
things that when people are growing up
they they get a buzz out of they they
want to know they they catch on to
rather than the the sort of identitarian
stuff which frankly at the end of the
day for many young people
it is extremely boring you're saying
point about somebody getting fired
over this well
we don't know if anybody hasn't been
fired over it first of all most uh
union cases and things like that are not
discussed beyond the case for kind of
obvious reasons and when people do go
very often there are agreements under
which they go and things like that but
there are seems to me there are quite a
few cases now of people being
investigated and this is actually in a
sense more important so neil finn up in
edinburgh was investigated because some
students didn't like him tweeting
very inoffensive things that he wasn't
completely in agreement with black lives
matter
he was investigated for this
can't a uni university management say
we've had a complaint there's nothing
here neil there's nothing here carry on
you know do they not have that authority
these days to to do that apparently not
apparently not as a union rep i find
that managers don't manage in in that
way they always defer
to uh you know investigating taking
everything
uh in that way but but my point is sorry
my my general point is this
if you risk
investigation
and possible censure
um
you're trying to make your career you're
trying to earn your living
you have to
consciously decide to to go down that
route and and and say what you think i
think many people say this and even use
university college union my union who
are very woke even their own research
shows that a lot of lecturers
self-censor
i don't want to self-censor i want to
have a climate in which we don't have to
even people whose views i
strongly disagree with i don't want them
to self-censor i want i respect their
views when i disagree with them and i
want them to respect my views to the
extent that we can talk about them
that's what our students deserve
that's what universities should be doing
you know that they deserve that
jim i'm going to be honest with you you
seem like a lovely bloke he's very
positive and very optimistic but but
you're going to mention the derby county
supporters
uh no uh
but the picture you're painting is bleak
it's really bleak
the fact that somebody has was
investigated for a tweet in which they
criticized a political organization like
blm and let's be fair let's be honest
about this
they were in danger of losing their job
simply for criticizing a political
organization
yeah
that means that
boys
the problem is with that number one
is it's showing that there's no real
freedom of speech on campus and number
two that is a warning shot to everybody
else
in your sector that if you criticize
this organization then you are going to
be for the chop
it is exactly right that's exactly what
it is and all of these other things like
the you know like the race equality
charter itself all of these things the
whole kind of infrastructure you know of
regulations and statements which put you
in you put you in that position and
that's why i'm saying
to say the number of people who've been
no platformed or sacked or something is
isn't the whole issue at all no you know
the issue is the culture you know that's
engendered uh by this
you're absolutely right about about that
but even this week and recently there
are people standing up to this there are
people prepared
not just individuals i mean at cambridge
arie farmids and some others stood up to
i think there i think i think basically
there the issue was um you know these
anonymous reporting tools you can report
people including their name nobody needs
to know who you are
um and and the whole microaggressions
thing they stood up to it and there was
some sort of vote there being a
cambridge college they do that kind of
thing there
and they won that this week professor
lee at kent university has been opposing
you know uh her students having imposed
upon them
a sort of you know uh training involved
involving deaf things about you know if
you buy second-hand clothes or some
nonsense
you might be committing a
microaggression
i can't even keep up with it you know
it's some of the stuff you don't
remember because it's so bizarre and
unbelievable and weird people are out
there standing up to it and i think that
um this year it would be a good idea
absolutely if more people stood behind
them in any way they can social media um
you know contacting people in their own
university very important our race
equality charter response
get it around a few people we're doing
that and we're getting some very good
responses of course you get that
pushback from the vocal activists and
that push back often is not a political
one we disagree with you in this way
it's
who are these people how can you say
that that shouldn't be said that's the
pushback but you always get other people
more likely under the radar
but often publicly too
saying
wow
is this is this how things are you know
we can't even question this well maybe
it shouldn't be done you know maybe it
shouldn't be like that
maybe at the very least our students
should be able to turn around and say
well
i don't see myself as white privileged
um
and therefore i'm not buying it yeah and
what percentage of the academics do you
think actually believe in this i know
it's a little bit of an unfair question
because but in your own but in your own
experience do a lot of them believe in
this do a lot of them support this or is
it kind of well
i'm on one hand we've had eric kavanaugh
to talk about the polling and the
research
well he'd probably know a lot more
in terms of the polling uh about that
i think it's very important to regard
academics as a group of people very
diverse very very diverse indeed and
a lot of these debates which people
characterized as culture war debates
um take place between
the debates themselves take place
between relatively small groups of
people
so it's a bit hard to say what
everything's because most people are
sitting looking on you know and thinking
that's a bit over the top you know i
agree with them but maybe not coming
forward
uh
at this at this at this stage
let me ask you so i wouldn't like to
give i wouldn't like to put a percentage
on it but i don't think it's the
majority of people who are ideologically
committed to um authoritarian divisive
work politics as we set it out in the
right our documents
i mean i i suspect that's very true and
also not necessarily that important
because all it takes is an intolerant
minority to get their will if they want
to but look i i hear you uh and you
don't divide us and others are doing
good work on opposing the stuff and it's
great to see as you say that people are
uh making successful efforts to to push
back against it
the one thing that i remember
before we started the show in
april 2018 i remember 2016 2017 seeing
videos from american college campuses
these sort of very stereotypical people
with you know pink hair and septum
piercings and whatever
boycotting or
no platforming people and all of that
and at the time i had the impression
that this was all student-led this was
driven by the students
since then i have also got the
impression that a lot of it has come
through the faculty through
the the teachers and the lecturers
teaching kids something and then
that activates them to behave in these
sort of ways
where do you think this is coming from
is this sort of bottom up are you
getting 18 year olds 19 year olds
turning up at your university full of
these ideas or is it more process of you
turn up to university
and you kind of maybe were sort of
thinking that way and then your beliefs
get reinforced how does that happen well
i think it's definitely the case that
anybody who is thinking that way you
know i've got this belief that must be
protected and all the rest of it
and i don't want people to you know
be able to kind of offend me or anything
like that i think anybody doesn't think
that way that their view will be
affirmed when they are on campus very
quickly you know i think that's the
point by him by universities by
universities i mean universities have
spent a number of decades developing
all sorts of um sort of speech codes and
uh regulations and things like that
which basically validate that so for
example
it wouldn't be unusual for a university
to have
anti-harassment
sort of
little bylaws for the university from
the students union and from the
university
and it wouldn't be unusual at all in
fact it would be commonplace standard
practice pretty much for those to say
that harassment can include many things
where you didn't even realize you were
harassing the person there doesn't need
to be any intent there at all it can be
entirely subjective
okay so you've got a situation there
where there might be a small number of
people with a particular belief but that
belief is validated by the institution
that they walk into i think your point
about staff
is a fair
point i mean
you tend to have
cliques and groups of people and that's
fine it's completely normal for groups
of people with common beliefs and so on
to get to get together
um and organize around things i'm
thinking about the no platforming
attempts at people like um
selena todd kathleen stark people like
that
they seem to come from from academics
and
i suspect at times students are brought
in as i'm not saying it's not there too
students are brought in as a stage army
you can't do this because our students
will be offended you know or
you know black students or trans
students or this group nobody's asked
the black students
my view is probably most will not be
offended and would be would
would not really like the idea that
their
identity is being sort of like treated
as a stage army to you know behind sort
of sensorious politics
but um
yeah a mixture
i guess but my
inclination
is to actually blame the institutions or
to look at the way that they have
cultivated a situation within which
relatively small groups of people um
who have
[Music]
the the kind of view that certain views
and identity should be protected and
free speech is he's secondary to that
that view is constantly validated and
supported and
that seems to me the way you know the
balance i would put on it how can these
institutions justify spending public
money
on on on these
on on these types of theories or
politics or supporting blm
why are is our tax money being being
used for this this doesn't help anybody
does it well i think it's a very very
good question especially a time when
universities are making lots of
redundancies
um and when many universities seemingly
can't get it together to provide lecture
theaters for everybody's lectures and
there's lots of stuff going on online in
the aftermath of covid and of course
it's to do with ventilation and covered
and things like that but i think it's
also to do with other things too
there is this new kind of vision of
university campuses as being like
virtual campuses where you show up a bit
like the open university used to be
except you do all this this this stuff
online
yeah i'm not sure really
uh in response to your question you know
because
shouldn't jim we come to a point where
institutions these institutions they
should be apolitical the police should
be a political the nhs should be
apolitical and so should universities
yeah absolutely i don't think
universities should be spending money on
things that
are directed at a particular political
philosophy a particular political
campaign or so on i think it's so
important that these institutions more
than any other remain and are seen to
remain neutral
because there's no other way in which a
university can fulfill its mission to
act as a kind of crucible for debate and
ideas
it's that that's absolutely imperative
so it it is well i i'm it's disgraceful
it is it absolutely is the money's being
spent on that i just qualify that by
saying there's a lot of goodwill a lot
of people trying to do good things but i
think
it's misguided
i'm not saying it's it's all of it is it
is some you know
people want to do good things and help
students black students in in many
respects but i don't think they do i
don't think they do even people with
goodwill who are trying to decolonize
the curriculum and things like that
uh you know our arguments are very much
that um
a lot of these
sort of critical race theory type of
arguments
they make assumptions about people they
re-racialize people they treat people as
identity groups uh with certain
attributes you know you're
um
likely to be microaggressed against
you're more likely to be a
microaggressor if you say these things
you have white privilege you're a victim
of white privilege
what's written out of this is the
individual the individual's passions
interests desires
and they're far more important far far
more important than than cultural
influences that can be assigned to
to different groups
so
so you're the optimist
you're the optimist right how do we get
from that which is what you're talking
about
to
where you want to be
well how do we do that how do we do that
that's why this conversation has this
negative hue because everything you're
saying
we sort of agree with and also know
because we've had these conversations
many times but as with many other people
when i'm asking
when we're trying to get from where we
are now which i think you've diagnosed
accurately to where you'd like to be
i'm not seeing that okay
all right
um well there's a couple of things going
on at them i mean
some people are looking at the sort of
legal routes as you know and the
government has been looking at uh
sort of um
as some people see it enforcing free
speech
so you know people can go to the office
for students or whoever
and you've got that that kind of route
and i used to be very very against that
you know um against any government
interference in universities whatsoever
anything that even appeared to resemble
government interference in universities
i'm a bit equivocal on it now because i
think that if i was an academic it was
under the cash facing
discipline for having an opinion
and there was nobody behind me i'd quite
like to have a law
to to draw on but i think the real the
real thing the really important thing
and
maybe i'm not going to convince you here
you know to be optimistic
i think the really important thing is to
try
different ways to
create a discussion and debate so
there's a you know people can say well i
do agree with this or i don't and i
don't think that fully exists at the
moment
there is a growing infrastructure around
this i mean there are organizations like
i think counterweight
ourselves over in america you've got
fair different different organizations
we didn't have that five years ago yep
so that's good so we're going some way
to providing that counter that counted
to that
i think the other thing that we're not
very good at at the moment that we've
got to develop as well as
ensuring that the debate happens
and convincingly criticizing
these ideas and i think we're not too
too bad at that we also need to
represent a new positive vision of the
university
because that's really what's going on
here the vision of our higher education
institutions what they're for what their
potential is
and i think we can excite young people
much more with a vision of a university
that you come to
from whatever background and those no
assumptions are made about you
the world is yours you know the ideas of
the world are yours
doesn't matter where they came from or
what color the person was who dreamt up
these ideas
or indeed whether they were funded at
some nefarious purpose
way in the past
a campus where
it's assumed that young people can get
together and trust each other to talk
without as i think it was at sheffield
university
without um people
paid to wander around and look for
you know i mean this is crazy stuff and
it was seen as such 10 years ago you can
see the sort of mission
mission creep there
so maybe that's the thing that we need
to do more of and do better really not
always focus our
uh
efforts on tackling these ideas that
we've got to do that's part of it
absolutely but also we tried to do this
a little bit in the race equality
charter um
response that we wrote
present a vision of a university that's
really inspiring for young people that
gets them excited about the world and
about knowledge
and not seeing the university is a place
to affirm your identity and defend it um
or to seek out you know the naysayers
and their etics and
make sure that they don't say what they
you know you don't want them to say but
a place where you go in
and you're going to take a few risks
intellectual risks maybe even a few
risks about being offended too at the
end of the day
um that sounds great the only thing
that's missing is a list of universities
where that is the case that you can
apply to
if you're a young person now who's
because i'm excited by that vision if i
were to take a year out from doing
whatever i'm doing or three years out to
go and do a degree
that excites me i think there will be a
lot of young people watch who watch
trigonometry who are excited by that
yeah
now you need a list of universities to
apply to where is that well i don't
think there's a list of university i
mean i think most young people who've
been to university uh well people can
have all sorts of views but let's say
somebody tuning into your show who
broadly agrees with with the sorts of
things that that you saying
i said they'll probably think of their
time at university and they'll say yeah
that lecturer really inspired me yeah
that's where i really learned what
economics or sociology or whatever it
was was all about that's where i
realized i'm here he's there or she's
there yeah and i'm gonna get there you
know
that that that kind of thing so it's not
this or that university i think it's
more down to individual members of staff
and you go to a university
and there are great teachers and i have
to say there are many fantastic teachers
on the other side of this argument sure
absolutely you know i mean i know people
myself
um who would be sitting here chomping at
the bit to disagree with what i'm saying
great you know and i'd love them did we
maybe we could do another show and they
could come and we could we could do we
could do something like that but um
you know that that's that's not
happening at the moment and uh you know
that that's the sort of thing that we
need to
ensure happens uh more more in the
future really jim
i'm i'm gonna ask you a question it's
not a particularly fair one but it's
just something that i believe honestly i
look at the universities they're
charging what nine grand a year
yeah yeah okay so they're charging nine
grand a year the value of a degree has
been completely devalued i think that's
fair to say in a lot of instances
yeah in terms of employment
in terms of in terms of employment in
terms of the quality of teaching contact
time university is now saying that you
know that the lectures are going to be
virtual
you look at a lot of degree courses nine
ten hours you're charging nine grand for
this
when are we just going to admit that
maybe the university sector is and now
that with all this stuff that we're
talking about
when we go should we just admit that
it's not fit for purpose
i think i think there's a difference
between saying that the university
sector isn't fit for purpose per se on
the one hand and on the other hand
saying that the university sector needs
to be seriously reformed yeah and i
think there is a real dearth of
discussion about reforming the
university sector um a colleague of mine
phil conliff and and somebody else
um wrote a really interesting put report
that um
features on the
keo
think tank website i reviewed it on
spike magazine as well looking at a sort
of future for universities very
different from the one we've got it
involved knowledge based institutions
fewer of them very competitive
and none of the woke yeah training and
things like that
it's very good i'd recommend people go
and have a look at that's on on the keo
uh think tank website and my thing on
spiked as well
um we need more of that we may not we
need more thinking out the box you know
universities have developed in you know
they've been really politicized i mean
that's the thing knowledge was really
politicized so
uh you had the old polytechnics which
were pretty good at training you know
they were good at training and you could
do your hnd they were good at getting
people into business
no it had to be a degree had to have
sort of parity in three years long
and then all the police became
universities and
then
all sorts of different things had to be
university status
courses that weren't
before and before you know it
uh a university has become this rather
indistinct
thing that encapsulates
training you know very practical things
um
as well as very kind of abstract
knowledge and it's trying to do all of
these things not doing perhaps any of
them as well as might as it might
so
i'm not sure about the sector
um
as a whole
but i absolutely do think there needs to
be a very serious
societal debate about where we're going
with the universities and the top of
that debate i think needs to be that we
need to have universities that are all
about uh knowledge
pushing the boundaries of knowledge
and that requires free speech
and that isn't
negotiable that really isn't negotiable
you can talk about all sorts of other
sensitivities and i'm very sensitive
myself to what my students say and and
feel and all the rest of it but we need
to start off with some basic principles
and those principles are the pursuit of
knowledge
and the ability to do that freely
without fear or favor on that happy note
i i was just going to say uh does he got
one more black people yeah
um
the introduction of tuition fees
particularly the bumping it up to nine
grand yeah part of
i see this as part of the problem
because what you've now turned students
into are customers and with a being a
customer comes with a sense of
entitlement and that entitlement is i
don't want to be confronted with things
that i disagree with yeah
well i think i think there's an element
of truth in that but i don't think it's
completely true i think one of the
arguments um that joanna williams makes
in her book on consuming education is
that
even if you were to take away the nine
grand
universities have already knowledge has
already been kind of compartmentalized
and made very instrumental as we said
said before you study this to get this
and you have these learning outcomes
that you have to meet and it's all very
mechanistic
and all of the woke stuff and all of
that that would be there without the
nine grand
so
i think the consumer mentality i'm here
so my views need to be respected because
i've paid for them you know all of those
things which
most students not really you know at the
front of their minds i have to say okay
you know students are you know they're
they're still there
bright-eyed bushy tail the problem is
what the universities tell them when
they arrive that's the problem you know
not what the universities think uh
before they arrive so they con the
consumer side of it that that's there
anyway and the nine and a half or nine
grand or whatever
is is
not such a big part of that and i can
think of situations in the past
historically
where people have paid for a brilliant
classical education you know you can pay
for something really good
maybe maybe down the line there's some
ideas about how the university my sector
might actually change
people offering
a different kind of education
and if you were paying for it you might
decide that's where your money will go
rather than
the way many universities seem to be
going at the moment
well choice would be good
very much on that note i hope your
positivity is merited mm-hmm and i hope
so too
good luck with don't divide us it's a
it's a great slogan um and let's hope uh
you can make that happen but in the
meantime uh we always end with the same
question which is what is the one thing
that we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
i would say you know we talk we're here
talking about universities and education
but perhaps the thing that we haven't
talked about that is worth talking about
is fun
i actually think university
that you know asked dear well clear the
students and their boss and they believe
me
but i i kind of vaguely remember in the
dark distant past having a lot of fun at
college at university yeah
still do have a little bit of fun but
you know back then it was fun and
exciting
and i tend to think that this
this impulse to to regulate you know to
to
you know even with the best intentions
to regulate how we speak to each other
and what gestures you know the
microaggressions thing and all of these
kind of things
i think it gets in the way of people
having fun you know and being
open
because we want people to take risks
and be open in terms of their
intellectual lives
but it's also
generally a good thing to be open
to experimenting a little bit and you
know with relationships and things like
that and just fun you know and trying
things
in in our personal lives and in our
leisure lives too
so more freedom in that respect you know
and and um
fun you know
and conviviality and togetherness all
the things we missed out
uh during the pandemic and everybody's
dying to get back into now you walk into
university and it's well
watch out for this watch out for
microaggressions these places are
dangerous
it's almost like fear is attaching
itself to
things that we always did you know
getting on having fun meeting new people
hanging out trying new sports music
whatever
um so fun that's the thing we should be
talking about that is a great thing to
be talking about we're going to ask you
a couple of questions for our local
supporters but in the meantime uh you
right for spiked uh where else can
people find you online uh well i've got
one of these sub stack things so i've
written for a few different uh
educational and other uh magazines and
things like that
arieo a little bit
so that's where they can find it look at
jim sub stack and it's pretty much all
on there i've written a few books
they're generally on
travel
and the cultures of travel and i did
actually write a book
that in a way in a very roundabout way
is a bit of a critique of woke travel it
was called the mobilization of tourism
so if you've never thought about
tourism in in the context of this i've
written a few things
around that as well another area of our
lives where very often we're told you
know you need a code of conduct you need
to be carefully destroying the
environment and all the rest of it and
so yeah
nothing escapes the the web of uh our
contemporary sort of woke culture i
think
jim thank you so much for coming on the
show it's been really enjoyed it thank
you
and if you've enjoyed this episode we
always put episodes out on wednesday and
sunday 7 p.m
also if you didn't enjoy them either we
still put them yeah yeah exactly they
will always go out uh 7 p.m uk time 2
p.m eastern standard our raw shows
always go out tuesday thursday friday
saturday same time and if you want your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below